la mort définitive du colisée est
maintenant annoncé sa démolition
commencera dès le mois de mai prochain
l'ancienne demeure des nordiques voyez
ce qui était sans doute sa dernière
folle aujourd'hui des nostalgiques de
tout âge venus récupérer leur petit bout
d'histoire
oui bah en fait on vient chercher c'est
pour l'histoire ses souvenirs en fait
c'est
c'est le bon souvenir pour tous les
chauffeurs de mieux voir ici c'est c'est
surtout pour ça moi lui c'est pour le
hockey la ville estime que le
démantèlement de l'édifice coûtera 8
millions de dollars et qui sera terminée
au bout de huit mois
dès décembre 2020 donc le colisée aura
disparu du paysage de québec une page
sera tournée
le nouveau chapitre qui s'ouvre est
rempli de promesses selon mr bah oui je
le rapport hier 1 contre les blue skies
puis on était bien à cette vidéo on
disait que les hommes d'avoir une peau
nous avons alors pensé le colisée peut
se vider ses sièges mais l'attachement
des partisans pour l'endroit demeure
impossible à déboulonner tous ceux
présents avec une anecdote à raconter du
papier toilette à tour de contrôle
c'était le but de peter stastny est
parti en plein milieu de la glace un
gain participer déjoué matt lio je me
rappelle toujours les premiers pas quand
j'ai fait pour la première game
tout le monde sent la quinzaine
personnes qui nous applaudit ces saumons
sont venus à leur place alors revenir
ici puis naturellement veut revoir les
anciens pu penser des bandits soir la
ville espère récolter 400 mille dollars
en vendant les sièges
une somme qui servira à financer la
démolition du colisée les partisans eux
ont leur morceau du passé en espérant
qu'une autre équipe de au pied les
soulèvent à nouveau de leur siège
et si sébastien tanguay radio canada à
québec